you guys bleep okay hey I'm Jake
hey I'm Emily and we've taught preschool
before and man is it wild I'm Keeley I
am a current preschool teacher
I'm Stephanie I used to be one being a
preschool teacher is great I love
teaching preschool but it does come with
it some crazy moments so many diapers oh
no so many diapers it's a roller coaster
and you know what else is a roller
coaster playing never have I ever
I'm played this since middle school
let's go let's do it never have I ever
been called mommy or daddy by a student
definitely have so embarrassed right
yeah oh yeah it's weird totally it's
real weird I got mr. daddy or I get the
ones that don't realize it at first its
although let's be like mommy mommy mommy
yeah I it happened to me when real mom
was in the room so Oh it's uncomfortable
it leads to a good conversation never
have I ever been given a cute gift by a
student I tell ya the best part it can
be anything
yeah piece of cardboard you're like oh
my god I mean five-year-olds so like the
drawings are not art but they're art
when I had my like goodbye celebration
after I moved from being a full-time
teacher to a substitute
they had the whole like little
celebration for me and they all brought
flowers I directed the theater show with
the the kids and they gave me a
director's chair with my name on it way
too much
very sweep away too much never have I
ever had to stop kids from doing
something naughty
you mean 24 hours a day even when I'm
not at work yeah what's the Nadia Nadia
isn't really a word we use in childcare
we don't say bad those generalizations
aren't welcome the enrichment center I
worked at um was very much about like
making positive statements whenever we
lost hope in kids like biting another
kid oh yes oh thank you yes no thank you
one boy I was teaching that one
was hosting a penis contest in the boys
room had to shut that down never have I
ever had to try to explain something
substantial to a child because they
asked oh oh I have oh boy I would say no
no you're lucky there was his book and
we were reading it and at one point it
was like and then like sometimes people
die and then what oh yeah it was like
what does that mean when someone dies
and I was like this is the moment yeah
I've been dreading I had a student who
thought the kiss of a wedding was what
produced a baby and he saw a kiss that
was not within a marriage and I tried to
get around it I tried to just say like
it doesn't happen then never have I ever
had to clean up pee poo or vomit
oh yeah I've definitely had to clean up
yeah every day every day every single
day many many times a minute yeah smile
add an addendum to this one
you ever been vomited on Oh totally yeah
I've been vomited on I think I can
honestly say I've cleaned up pee poop
and vomit in the last week all like yeah
that's a great feeling
they choose you never have I ever had a
favourite child in class oh I think
that's a lie I've had so many favourites
and I tried really hard not to let them
know it but they always knew yeah I
think I'm gonna say I haven't just
because like they all have something
like something unique to offer like if
I'm like what is here this I have for
sure how to favorite and it may or may
not have to do with what their parents
get you for Christmas
oh never have I ever had to tell the a
parent their child had misbehaved in
school or your kid misbehaves I am
telling you immediately had to write
some emails
since like you know the penis
competition well you that was definitely
a big one we have to make sure we're
very sensitive with those things yeah so
the parents don't get like scared or
feel like they're being judged because I
think that's one thing that parents are
really oh yeah really scared about use
kid gloves with the adults mm-hmm never
have I ever been asked out by a parent
like I said minor much older than me
sadly no I'm grateful truly
isn't that the rom-com fantasy that
world we are all thinking of
never have I ever experienced a child
say something inappropriate they say
things that are just so hilarious
sometimes I think kids favorite thing to
do is to tell you when you don't look
good that day oh yeah lots of cursing
kids repeat oh yeah so if you don't want
your kid to say chode like all of those
never have I ever been yelled at by a
parent Oh moment of pride I'm not
diffused then who's yelled at I felt
cornered a little bit by parents oh yes
totally have been yelled at by a parent
I've been yelled at by a parent in a
classroom I've been yelled at and by a
parent through a group text yeah yeah
that's theatre parents but never have I
ever been made fun of by a child and I
was told I yell a lot but it was like I
was I exaggerate you know I get into it
I get animated it I get excited about it
and why just take it down a notch I said
I was at 11 and if he could be getting
me at 5 never have I ever been friends
with a student's family uh like yeah me
neither
I have actually
I have not no yeah I've I've been like
acquaintance see mm-hmm but I've I have
I've had a boundary thing with that
that's like very proud of on yeah at
least at the police I worked it's very
like not okay and I technically was
friends with his family before I got the
job at the school I got and before their
oldest students started going in some
being a preschool teacher is grueling
it's crazy nuts nuts nuts bananas we do
a lot more nerd in our day with so many
kids so many other teachers so many
parents I think a preschool teacher is a
hard job but someone's gonna do yeah but
totally worth it it's totally worth it
well this with preschool what you see is
what you get and we help you know start
kids off as who they are and so
hopefully this was enlightening but not
too terrifying I hope we're not freaking
name by out from ever having kids or
teaching preschool
you're just a subset of the population
but we tell the truth
[Music]